sin prestigio sin cordura sin sorpresas
los premios globos de oro están
acostumbrados a este aguacero de
críticas pero si hoy en cultura los
abrimos en canal no es porque su gala
fuera aburrida con jodie foster en
pijama y una audiencia que apenas pudo
ver las obras sino porque esta edición
que elogió a estas películas principales
de estas series de televisión arrancando
la temporada 2021 ha dejado a estos
premios con el agua al cuello al no
atender esta coyuntura de cambio o auge
de la industria
[Música]
tiene semanas
comenzamos esta interpretación con
amatlán como mejor drama no admite
debate reconocida ya en venecia y
toronto es la historia sencilla pero no
simple de una profesora que pierde a su
marido su trabajo y su hogar en nevada
por la crisis económica y entra en ese
grupo de nómadas a cuatro ruedas que
encadenan trabajos temporales un rato
crudo y no romántico de una clase obrera
sin destino final que a la vez se
encuentra viviendo el duelo con la
aceptación y el abandono con la unión y
la empatía cuál es la pega que la
cineasta china estadounidense chloe chau
haya protagonizado una competencia
inédita por la dirección con las
directoras regina king quien ve la lpf
en él siendo la segunda realizadora
galardonada en 78 ediciones
[Música]
pues no
y por qué
[Música]
o sí
así de media
pero hay nuevos
[Música]
como soy
hasta ahora barbara streisand estaba
sola entre directores y no abogamos por
una elección por género pero si una
mayor representación y ahora que se le
ha exigido a la asociación de la prensa
extranjera de hollywood ésta ha
respondido pasándose de corrección
política siempre tuvo en sus galas
variedad técnicas si bien se nota en los
actores de cine el haber primado
diversidad para froome ante mérito la
mayor evidencia es andrés de por su
encarnación dramática de la cantante
billie holliday que supone su segunda
actuación y es notable aunque menor
respecto a los roles de francés
mcdormand vanessa kirby o mayo la davis
esta última es la madre del blues junto
al fallecido chadwick foxman que se ha
llevado a ser mejor protagonista
dramático de nuevo frente a anthony
hopkins y gary oldman que no como
músicos pero sí como enfermo de demencia
y guionista en la época dorada de
hollywood ostentan enormes
interpretaciones
nunca me emociono mucho cuando un año en
particular veo un aumento de la
representación de un grupo excluido lo
que me gustaría ver es una tendencia en
el tiempo
estamos de acuerdo galas que se tildan
de históricas por sus valores o
diversidad en las tramas ya no valen
debe haber una normalización continua y
aquí la responsabilidad es de la
asociación de la prensa lo señaló jane
fonda al recibir el globo honorífico
cecil b de mil los hay que tienen el
poder de que todas las historias tengan
oportunidad de ser vistas sólo que como
hacerlo en un grupo que es una ong
exenta de impuestos con 87 personas que
no siempre son periodistas
ninguno afro que desde 2003 y sólo deben
cumplir con basarse en los ángeles y
seis visionados o artículos al año de
ahí las acusaciones de corrupción
generalizada y obstrucción a la
membresía que debe ser apoyada por dos o
tres asociados
sin duda el mayor cambio que deben
asumir los globos es su asociación por
una demanda de un crítico noruego al que
rechazaron admitir más una investigación
de los ángeles times' ahora está en la
mira si bien esta falta de ética y
aprovechamiento de su poder con los
estudios esta vida desde hace años en la
gala que en los oscar cuenta con casi 10
mil académicos se los tildó de blancos y
fantasmas uno de sus integrantes de más
de 90 años ni siquiera ve ni escucha
mientras que la nominación de emily de
parís es sólo otro caso de invitación de
lujo en parís para ver el set y dormir
en un hotel de 5 estrellas
en cierto modo los globos de oro y la
asociación son una especie de monstruo
creado por los propios estudios no es un
grupo objetivo y riguroso sino que son
personas sobre las que se tienen la
percepción de que pueden ser compradas e
influenciadas
por todo esto sin desmerecer a de chan
ya los de chicago se vende short king
con un sacha baron cohen igual de
atrevido en borat mejor cinta y actor de
comedia o las grandes series de crown y
de queens gambit que aceleran la
consagración de netflix proponemos mirar
en los márgenes suena a la carta de amor
pero averigüen más de ese eeuu profundo
que esconde hechos como el asesinato del
líder de black danzas por parte del fbi
y la policía de chicago
o del encarcelamiento de 14 años en
guantánamo de un mauritano sin cargos ni
juicio el miércoles
ya en lo foráneo en la francesa chiapas
encontrarán un amor secreto entre dos
mujeres jubiladas en la danesa another
round se sumarán a un experimento
filosófico sobre el alcohol con el
dilema de qué pasaría si lo usáramos
para vivir sin miedo mientras que con la
guatemalteca la llorona verán el terror
que falta en premios así porque más que
miedo es genocidio e injusticia
cuando nos irán a dejar en paz
l
[Música]
cuando decimos que las cintas de esta
edición se conocen menos es cierto a
medias
muchos están y son originales en
plataformas solo que su auge no ha
podido con el filtro y escaparate que
supone un cine y eso que tienen todo en
contra en españa sólo el 39 por ciento
de las salas siguen abiertas aún sin
hollywood sin sesión nocturna y sin
comida resisten con clásicos y títulos
independientes por eso que nueva york
vuelva al ruedo tras casi un año de
cierre es una gran noticia aunque los
exhibidores del estado reabrirán con 25
por ciento de aforo o máximo 50
espectadores
su retorno permitirá confiar en estrenos
globales lo que anhelan todos incluida
ciudad de mexico
apenas puede sumar un 20 por ciento de
butacas perdiendo también dinero en
ventilación y limpieza pero busca que la
cinefilia pueda más que todas las
segundas y terceras clausuras
ante esta sangría económica hoy tras
bambalinas se plantea si el cina está
muriendo o está resucitando en otra
definición en cualquier caso el público
siempre es clave y eso espera en su
apuesta en salas habilitadas chaos
walking dead' o kleeman público su
planteamiento con base literaria
distópica seduce imaginan un planeta con
una sociedad masculina en la que todos
los pensamientos se revelan en imágenes
y sonidos llamados el ruido todos salvo
los de mayo la una joven que da cuenta a
tot que esta cacofonía no afecta a ellas
lo cual lleva a otras preguntas en qué
clase de mundo desaparecerían las
mujeres que oculta cómo sería una vida
sin privacidad
los británicos beige y ridley tom
holland sostienen estas reflexiones en
una dirección de cuatro años debido a
sus agendas starworks spider-man además
de tomas adicionales algunas
planificadas el resto del elenco lo
forman los actores matt mikkelsen y
cynthia herivaux y el cantante nick
jonas
aunque el pulso inicial es del escritor
y co-guionista patrick nes si aún no
pueden verla cuentan con sus libros
no
en el portal de cross eva tu signo
agregando oferta el streaming disney
flash también presenta raya y el último
dragón del oscarizado donald y sobre
estas dos avisos en junio se podrá ver
sin costo extra mientras que su aventura
transcurre por un mensaje sencillo que
es confíe en los demás salvo por esto el
filmes de esta época y se agradece se
agradece que las animaciones ya no sean
de princesas o de amor sino guerreras
que no tienen por qué pelear cantando la
misión de raya es unir a su pueblo y
salvar al mundo de unas criaturas
malignas que antaño fueron destruidas
gracias a la magia de los dragones
por ello raya busca al último legendario
una épica que se conoce más aquí se
trata con diversidad cultural con toques
de videojuego y cierta volpe
sargent
despierte
broker
[Música]
y bueno
casi todas del mueble
con los globos de oro hemos hablado del
estado de los premios del alcance del
streaming de la crisis del cine y sus
salas y claro de ningún cambio escapa el
resto de la industria esta semana lo ha
evidenciado el festival de la berlinale
más bizarro que nunca y partido en dos
con una parte para profesionales y otra
con previsión de eventos en junio pero
su lucha por la no invisibilización ha
chocado con rarezas como un reproductor
para ver cintas a 8 veces su velocidad
iremos tratando su selección oficial
pero este es el futuro mejor
transformación e impensable antes del
mito es respeto en escena una campaña de
actrices y directores latinoamericanas
que entenderán con la frase de su
impulsora brasileña la realizadora en
lucían a ser bulo y es que el sistema
patriarcal en el que vivimos se refleja
en un set de filmación hace años sufrió
abuso psicológico y con esta web muchos
profesionales buscan señalar esas
violencias y abusos que sufren las
mujeres en cine teatro y televisión así
como crear un código ético regional sólo
en brásil
en este sector el 59 por ciento
mujeres sentían en 2017 que por su
género sus opiniones no contaban
[Música]
séptimo arte' y pequeña pantalla así ha
sido esta semana y así nos despedimos
disfruten de la banda sonora y canción
elegidas por los globos sol y la vita
davanti s respectivamente cuídense y
gracias
[Música]
si buscas
daban
hace